bonjour jacqueline eustache brinio bien
joué merci d'être avec nous ce matin en
direct sur arte france à votre
commentaire d'abord sur ces hommages qui
ont eu lieu hier à avignon et sur les
champs elysées jean castex et gérald
darmanin doivent recevoir ce soir les
syndicats de police pour leur assurer
une meilleure sécurité
écoutez d'abord les préconisations de
jean castex et on en parle après
notamment suite au drame de rambouillet
j'ai décidé de dégager immédiatement une
enveloppe de 10 millions d'euros pour
renforcer la sécurité des commissariats
de police
alors ça c'est pour l'attentât de
rambouillet contre le terrorisme sinon
des caméras piétons vont être
multipliées est ce que c'est la bonne
solution selon vous d'abord il ya deux
choses d'abord le fait que les policiers
rendu hommage à leur collègue c'est
important mais je pense que on voit bien
aujourd'hui l'exaspération des policiers
sur ce qui se passe dans notre pays
voilà là on a eu une nature
administrative d'un commissariat à un
mollet qui a été égorgé on a là un
policier avignon qui a été abattu de
sang froid
on peut mettre tous les moyens tous les
moyens les caméras piétons on peut
mettre tout ce qu'on veut des caméras
dans l'espace public n a beaucoup
maintenant et ça permet aussi de mener
des enquêtes un peu plus rapidement
quand on recherche des personnes mais
mais le problème de fond le problème de
fond et les policiers de 10 et un
certain nombre de politiques le disent
c'est l'impunité de ces délinquants de
ses volets ou qui sont dans les
quartiers qui se sentent aujourd'hui les
rois parce que pour la plupart d'entre
eux ils ne craignent rien alors d'abord
ce sont des jeunes pour lequel la limite
l'interdît n'existe pas n'existe pas la
preuve haïti reçoit des policiers ils
attaquent des élus donc ils sont hors
tous orne hommes et ils sont en plus
dans l'impunité
parce qu'ils ne risquent pas tiquement
rien alors évidemment cette nuit
d'ailleurs gelé rendant hommage aux
policiers et aux services de sécurité
qui ont a priori arrêté deux suspects
dans la sphère d'avignon donc ça on
verra bien le parcours de ces deux
jeunes mais vous
et on va encore nous dire il était connu
des forces de police il était connu par
la justice
mais il leur est arrivé crois quoi rien
donc enfin ce sont des jeunes qui se
construisent dans cette espèce
d'impunité ou commettre un délit
quelques histoires ça n'a pas
d'importance parce qu'il n'y a pas de
sanction alors la justice du dic ces
parts valent bien si c'est vrai c'est
vrai quand vous avez des jeunes qui sont
convoqués
juste pour un rappel à la loi on leur
dit c'est pas bien tu vas pas
recommencer ou des jeunes qui sont
convoqués des mois après leur délit pour
des sanctions qui ne sont pas appliquées
ou en tout cas qui ne représentent rien
et bien nous sommes notre tour nos vies
nos quartiers notre pays
ben voila moi je dis nous sommes un
danger permanent aujourd'hui et les
policiers expriment très très bien ce
sont des gens extrêmement courageux qui
vont regarder ce qui se passe à avignon
qui font leur travail mais dans des
conditions aujourd'hui d'angoissé
d'inquiétude qui pose quand même
question parce que c'est vrai que un
jeune aujourd'hui qu'ils auraient
souhaité peut-être s'engager dans la
police il doit se poser des questions
quand même moi je vraiment jeté rendent
hommage à ces policiers qui pour l'heure
qu'ils ne baissent pas les bras mais qui
alerte sur les conditions terrifiante de
travail qu'ils font regarder quand il y
a des mortiers qui sont lancés quand
même sur la police aujourd'hui la police
elle recule c'est insupportable de voir
nos policiers reculer c'est à dire
baisser les bras alors il ya peut-être
aussi alors je le dis ça plaît pas à
tout le monde quand je dis ça nous
doctrine à une doctrine à remettre en
place c'est à dire que voilà un moment
il va falloir que ce ne soit pas les
policiers qui recule mais ce soit les
délinquants qui recule et qu'on les
arrête
dans les cas par dont vous parliez des
alertes de la part des policiers il ya
aussi les militaires qui ont sonné
l'alertent si je puis dire on se
souvient de la tribune des généraux de
la semaine dernière une nouvelle tribune
deux militaires d'actifs cette fois dont
des militaires en exercice va paraître
dans valeurs actuelles
et ils font le même constat finalement
que leurs aînés situation chaotique au
bord d'une guerre civile même regarder
cet extrait de cette tribune à paraître
ce sont ces milliers de serviteurs de la
france signataires d'une tribune de
simple bon sens
des soldats qui ont donné leurs plus
belles années pour défendre notre
liberté
obéissant à vos ordres pour faire vos
guerres ou mettre en oeuvre vos
restrictions budgétaires que vous avez
sali alors que le peuple de france les
soutenait alors nouvelle tribune à
paraître
on sait que beaucoup de ses signataires
anonymes ont fait partie de des fameuses
sentinelle qui ont sillonné d'ailleurs
les quartiers pour lutter contre le
terrorisme ils connaissent bien le
terrain ils ont aussi beaucoup combattu
dans les opérations extérieures
il faut un constat sur un terrain qu'ils
connaissent finalement bien évidemment
vous savez aujourd'hui dans ce qu'on
appelle les quartiers où les zones un
peu difficile
il a trois sujets il ya là des la petite
délinquance primaire qui polit d'avec
les habitants et à les trafiquants de
robes de drogue pardon il y a les
salafistes et les islamistes y voilà il
ya ça c'est une réalité petit monde qui
ce soutien parce que dans ces trois
mondes la personne n'a intérêt à ce que
la police vienne ce que chacun fait son
petit business où chacun met en place sa
stratégie d'isolement pour les
islamistes donc tout le monde tout le
monde ce soutien et ses militaires moi
je voudrais leur rendre hommage parce
que d'abord les ministères certains un
certain nombre soient engagées dans des
terrains extérieurs pour nous protéger
on est parfois seul un peu de la france
d'ailleurs pour nous protéger de ces
terroristes qui sont un peu éloignés
notre pays mais qui sont là donc je vais
leur rendre hommage et les militaires il
exprime il exprime ce que beaucoup de
français etc se sentent aujourd'hui vous
savez ça effectivement 54% des français
et oui effectivement 54% des français
les soutiennent alors la plupart des
français partagent en tout cas ce que
disent et militaires alors la guerre
civile bon je pense que on n'en est pas
là mais on est dans un climat
même très inquiétant vous savez il ya
trois phénomènes récents qu'il ne faut
pas négliger la semaine dernière il ya
des habitants à paris pour lancer des
mortiers sur les trafics de drogue à
saly grade parce qu'ils en avaient à
assier de ces trafics et de ses
consommateurs de crack
ce sont les habitants qui les ont
éloignés de leurs habitations parce
qu'ils vivent l'enfer on a aussi sur des
squats des habitants qui se sont
mobilisés pour faire partir des
squatters parce que ben l'état ne le
faisait pas si quand même inquiétant que
dans un pays d'état ne protège plus et
que des habitants
voilà solistes on va le faire nous mêmes
moi je ne souhaite pas ça je ne le
souhaite pas mais en tout cas ce climat
là il existe et je dire quand on sent
que parfois les habitants pensent que
l'état ne les protège pas ou que l'état
ne fait pas à partir du moment où c'est
les habitants bas prennent les choses en
main ya de quoi s'inquiéter
et on peut pas voilà on peut pas
sous-estimer sous-estimer ce climat là
qui existent en france où des habitants
dont peut-être idiot on va se
débrouiller tout seul ça c'est injuste
insupportable et la police qui est là
pour nous protéger la police qui fait un
travail extraordinaire quand depuis une
semaine on entend protégeant la police
certes maintenant on se dit il faut
qu'on protège la police alors que la
question devrait même pas se poser même
pas se poser
donc c'est ses frais franchement et puis
il faudrait j'aurais eu dire aussi que
tous les hommes politiques engagées dans
ce pays qu'il soit d'extrême droite à
d'extrême gauche est le même discours
parce qu'on a aussi ça on a quand même
un certain nombre de politiques qui ont
critiqué sans arrêt la police qui ont
effectivement par les violences
policières en permanence comme si
c'était le cas oui s'il est parfois il
ya des excès mais il faut dire comme
dans toute profession il ya des gens qui
sont balout fin de la saison mais il n'y
a pas de violences policières
quand on regarde les violences urbaines
ces les policiers qui sont nés ses
palais d'iéna ou très rarement les
délinquants
donc voilà il faut il faut qu'on ait un
discours très clair sur ce sujet et que
l'on soit tous d'accord au delà nos
divergences politiques parce que on en a
sur la police est là pour protéger les
habitants et la police on la soutient et
les délinquantes
sur en face on doit les arrêter voilà et
peut-être juguler mais ça c'est pas le
sujet je trouve ce sujet votre réaction
politique
jacqueline eustache brinio justement sur
cette image là qu'on a vu lors du 8-mai
emmanuel macron entouré de de ses
généraux pour faire corps autour du chef
de l'état montrer l'unité ça même été
qualifié d'historique 1 dans certains
médias est-ce que c'est pas plutôt delà
de la mise en scène quand on voit qu'il
ya une tribune qui va paraître
finalement ça ça des meules et
complètement cette stratégie d'unité
affichée c'est c'est de la com est
président il aime bien faire de la com
donc ça c'est de la com c'est l'image de
l'armée qui soutient l'état m'enfin
d'abord l'armée
voilà là pour ça il n'y a jamais eu
celles qui sont si jamais le projet
question est là car lens c'est de la com
et via sur ces deux là comme s'était
vous montrer les militaires sont à mes
côtés
c'est pas comme ça qu'on règle le
problème le président je pense qu'ils ne
mesurent pas ils ne mesurent pas l'état
de notre société en matière d'
inquiétudes en matière de fractures ce
que ce pays est fracturée et moi je
reste persuadé que lui la fracture et
encore je ne dis pas que il est
responsable de tout mais il a fracturé
davantage de ses plis parce qu'il a été
incapable de prendre des décisions très
claires sur internement de sujet est la
politique du en même temps est une
politique catastrophique pour notre pays
clairement les errements on va parler du
fan aurait fait un homme qui arrive au
sénat pour inscrire la lame le climat la
protection du climat en tout cas dans la
constitution c'est ce qu'avait laissé
entendre l'exécutif hier il n'y aura
plus de référendum
est ce que c'est de la faute de vous des
sénateurs comme le dit l'exécutif
si vous voulez quand ça va pas bien
c'est ça non c'est pas la faute des
sénateurs d'abord vous savez on est dans
un agenda législatif un peu compliqué
bon d'abord on a eu tous les textes
concernant la crise sanitaire qui ont
évidemment décalé décalé le calendrier
après on a des textes qui nous arrive
parfois pas prévu donc effectivement le
référendum il a empanné lire parce que
clairement clairement l'agenda
législatif est très compliqué et très
resserré on va arriver
en septembre octobre dans une période
pré-électorale et on peut pas bousculer
les agendas
il ya des règles savions pas la preuve
du sénat sauf que quand on s'engage
quand on fait des promesses mais qu'on
ne maîtrise pas d'agenda ou qu'entre 2
on nous impose des choses essentielles
parce qu'il ya des choses importantes
c'est pas la faute du sénat et puis
sincèrement moi je veux dire ce que je
pense
la loi climat le référendum tout ça
c'est intéressant le président il a ni
autour de lui des habitants des
représentants associatifs cetera il leur
a donné beaucoup d'espoir et puis
sincèrement il n'a pas gardé grand chose
mais ça on connaît la méthode mais
est-ce que très sincèrement c'est très
important
voilà à préserver la planète
faire en sorte que tout le monde puisse
avoir conscience que nous devons
préserver incertaine en somme un certain
nombre de choses
aujourd'hui les bonnes mains c'est très
très important mais traite aujourd'hui
est ce que les français c'est leur
priorité principale aujourd'hui on ne
peut pas je ne dis pas qu'il faut pas en
parler mais aussi sanitaire ses seins
ben voilà on à la crise sanitaire qui
est quand même depuis un an voilà on vit
dans un climat un peu particulier on va
souhaiter pour tout le monde que les
choses se passent bien dans ce décor
finement qui est programmée bon voilà
mais et puis voilà entre la crise
sanitaire les problèmes de sécurité
je suis pas sûr que les français là
référendum aujourd'hui du climat ça
serait essentiel pour eux en tout cas je
suis pas sûr que ce soit à quelques mois
après mois mais il aura pas lieu
non ça reste en tout cas une question le
climat reste une question importante à
ses yeux des français
merci beaucoup jacqueline eustache
brinio d'avoir répondu ce matin en
direct à nos questions sur les forces au
revoir